javascript allows you to select elements
from the Dom of a website and then make
changes to those elements first I'm
gonna go over ways to select these
elements using javascript up here I have
the HTML and you can see down here is
where the HTML is being rendered and the
JavaScript I'm gonna put up here so here
we have document dot get element by ID
so we're going to find an ID in the
document over here and it's gonna be div
1 so that's going to select this entire
element right here because the ID is div
1 and you can pass any ID if I pass them
div 2 it would select this section right
here now I have get elements by class
name and I've passed in a class name
unicycle something to look at here is
this word elements it's a plural that
means you're gonna get all elements that
have that class name as we have it it's
going to select this element and this
element both of them have the class of
unicycle and a lot of these can be
called on any element not just the
document so instead of letting document
here if I put div 1 it's only gonna
select the elements that have class
unicycle in div 1 so here's div 1 and we
would only select this item that has the
class unicycle we would not select this
one because that's not in div 1 but for
now I'm going to change this back to
document and now we have get elements by
tag name it's kind of like the previous
one except instead of passing a class
name you're gonna pass a tag name so
that would just be this PEP
so this will get all the paragraphs in
the document so here here here but again
if I put something like div 1 here we
would only get the paragraphs in div 1
now this is showing query selector for
query selector you can pass in a string
containing one or more CSS selectors
separated by commas and this is going to
return the first element within the
document that matches that selection now
this can be used to find the same things
you found in the above methods for
instance when
we pass and this is the query selector
that's gonna be the same thing is just
finding the first item with the class
name unicycle or we can put it in like
this and that's gonna be the same thing
as finding the first element with an ID
of let's changes to div two now you can
also do query selector all kind of like
query selector but now we're returning
an array of elements you can pass some
different items to match so this is
gonna match the class unicycle and this
is gonna match the ID div to so you can
get every item that has the class
unicycle or the ID div to now once
you've selected the element there are
different things you can do with them in
this video I'll just show you how to set
new text or HTML so first I have a text
variable that just has an h1 tag with
the word words hello world inside and
now I'm gonna set div one which you can
see up here which is document dot get
element by ID div one I'm going to set
the inner HTML to text that means I'm
going to replace all the HTML inside div
one with this new HTML so look div one
is right here so this whole thing is div
one it's the whole thing's gonna be
replaced with just this new HTML so
let's run that and see what happens as
you can see it replace everything in
that in this blue line here with with
hello world and now let's try it on
query unicycle and let's change this
since it's create a unicycle this should
be unicycle and on that and the first
class with unicycle has changed to hello
world now a lot of these are actually
giving you an array of elements remember
so to change things in an array of
elements you're gonna have to use a loop
so let me comment out then we see this
loop we're gonna go through the whole
query all length so for every element
that we've queried in query all we're
gonna set the inner HTML to the text so
let's run that
you can see here we have three hello
worlds because this is getting every
unicycle and then the div too so we have
this became hello world that's class
unicycle
this became hello world and then this
whole thing section right here became
hello world now there is a security risk
whenever you use innerhtml
especially when you're setting strings
over which you have no control this
could open you up to a cross-site
scripting attack for that reason it is
recommended that you not use inner HTML
when inserting plain text instead you
can use text content like this and let
me just comment this out and text
content is not going to interpret the
past content as HTML but just inserts it
as raw text so if I run that it's going
to have the h1 tags right in there it's
just gonna put the raw text instead of
trying to create the actual heading in
the page and you can do that for any of
these examples we've seen already well
thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good